n'a jamais changer :
faire aimer la science.
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
♪ Les Débrouillards ♪
- Depuis 40 ans, on s'amuse
avec la science dans
le magazine des "Débrouillards".
Et pour son infatigable
illustrateur, il y a
de quoi célébrer.
JACQUES GOLDSTYN,
illustrateur, Les Débrouillards
- Les années ont passé.
On voit les enfants, on voit
la deuxième, des fois
la troisième génération. Donc,
c'est un bel accomplissement.
- Je dois malheureusement
vous informer que le professeur
Scientifix ne peut pas être
avec nous.
- Tout a commencé avec
le succès de ce premier livre
d'expériences scientifiques
pour les jeunes. Son auteur,
Félix Maltais, décide alors
de lancer en janvier 1982
un magazine d'abord baptisé
"Je me petit-débrouille".
SARAH PERREAULT, rédactrice
en chef, Les Débrouillards
- À l'époque, ça existait pas
ce genre d'activités
scientifiques qui s'adressaient
à une clientèle aussi jeune.
- Qu'est-ce qui va se passer,
vous pensez?
- Le populaire magazine a
propulsé tout un mouvement
entre autres avec des ateliers,
des camps de jours et,
à un moment, avec une émission
de télévision intitulée
"Les Débrouillards", co-animée
par Marie-Soleil Tougas
et Gregory Charles.
- Qu'un produit qui est parf
se vend beaucoup mieux
qu'un même produit parfumé.
- On est devenu des vrais
spécialistes des trompe-nez.
GREGORY CHARLES, co-animateur de
l'émission "Les Dés"
- J'ai un lien émotif fort
pour toutes sortes de raisons,
j'ai aussi un lien d'admiration.
Je crois encore à l'importance
ça. On s'est posé
la question très, très
longtemps à propos du déficit
qu'il y avait entre les garçons
et les fet les fet les fet les .
Bien, je pense que
les Débrouillards, c'était
une partie de la... pasla solute
de la solution. Alors,
j'admire les gens qui continuent
à faire ça. Je serai toujours,t.
- Pour la biochimiste Marianne
Desautels-Marissal, la magazine
a été source d'émerveillement.
MARIANNE DESAUTELS-MARISSAL,
journaliste scientifique
- C'était la section
des expériences que j'attendais
le plus avec impatience.
Je pense que j'ai coûté cher
en bicarbonate de soude
et en colorant alimentaire
à mes parents. Mais je pense que
ça m'a aussi donné le goût
de vulgariser et de communiq
moi aussi, la science,
ce que je fais maintenant.
Puis, j'ai aussi été
animatrice au camp de jour
des Débrouillards quand
j'étais au cégep.
- Aujourd'hui, le mouvement
a plus d'une expérience
dans son sac avec ses trois
magazines et son balado.
Une nouvelle émission de télé
est en chantier.
Jacques Goldstyn ne compte pas
déposer ses crayons de sitôt.
- Je vais rester jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie avec
les Débr
(rires)
- Car après tout, Débrouillard
un jour, Débrouillard toujours.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
anada, Monanada, Monanada, Mona.